[Music]
hey
here we are back once again yeah what's
up ladies and gentlemen
yes monday yeah we were uh
trying to figure out what it was we're
going to watch last night i almost
watched that one that had
that had well what's his name unhinged
maybe we can watch that tonight
uh jenny looked down and she went look
man peninsula's there so i said yeah
let's do that i was gonna rent it off at
xbox couldn't rent it had to buy it
so i bought that [ __ ] a digital copy
you know yeah they wouldn't let you rent
it
but that well because he was just gonna
rent it and he's like well he would have
rented it for 14.99 which is how much
the
high definition was right yeah but it
was like it was viable
you had to buy only yeah but we've been
like waiting to see that because i know
a couple of y'all had seen it
yeah because i think it played in some
theaters like a limited release
so we've been waiting a long time to see
it so i was actually really excited that
we saw it while we were like farting
around looking yeah i was really
interested in how it was going to go
because some people said that it wasn't
it wasn't as good as the first one
and i just have to say it was different
they took it in a different direction
but it was good i liked it i liked it
yeah i mean well the thing about it is
that when you come out with a movie like
train to busan um it's kind of hard to
top that
yeah and even though this is it's the
same director
um a lot of the crew was the same
but i'm not sure like i liked this movie
but
it's it was a bigger movie it had yeah
like the scope of it was a lot larger
and it had a lot of post-apocalyptic
stuff in it which i liked it was
it kind of went fury road yeah a lot of
people compared it to that yeah there
were car chases and stuff
and uh fighting from car to car and part
of it it was um
the pandemic the the zombie outbreak got
contained on the korean peninsula that's
how the story goes
but a lot of koreans ended up being kind
of like refugees they could they had to
leave korean couldn't get back couldn't
go back there
and they were living in places like uh
taiwan and china and
actually he was in hong kong one yeah he
was in hong kong he's in hong kong and
they're kind of down on their luck
and he runs into these criminals there's
an american with them and stuff it's
like this criminal gang
and this criminal gang gives them and
gives them an uh an opportunity to make
some money
they knew about a truck that had
millions of dollars in it
and they had been abandoned on a bridge
out somewhere in seoul i guess wouldn't
seoul there was an inch on yeah it was
in china i think
and i said if they could get them there
that they would get them there and if
they could get that money out of that
truck they'd give them half of it which
was like about a million and a half
ahead it was two and a half million
ahead two and a half minutes i think
there was 20 million dollars in the
truck
so these guys go on this mission they're
kind of like a rag tag
a bunch of ex-soldiers and just koreans
i think there's about six of them they
try to
they try to find that truck and bring it
back but it's not so easy
not only are there zombies there's a
bunch of there's like there's like uh
uh like post-apocalyptic gangs
yeah so there's like a thunder dome yeah
with zombies and stuff
because i guess this one it's i don't
even know if i would call it a
sequel to trendy busan it's like a
follow-up
it's set in the same universe but it's
not like any of the same characters it's
like four years later
um so you can totally watch this one
without having seen train to busan
and you won't be like what the [ __ ] is
going on like it's very easy to like
figure out
this one also kind of it kind of uh
folds right in with that other korean
zombie movie that we saw the guy was
trapped in that apartment oh yeah
yeah remember that one yeah who's the
name of that you remember uh [ __ ] um
you could watch alive or something yeah
live you could watch all three of them
and it's it's taking place in the same
universe
yeah because actually the zombies in
that looked pretty similar pretty much
zombies in this
yeah and and it was it was part of the
outbreak remember the military was
involved and they had some guys
it was about the same so it's almost
kind of you could say all three of those
movies are in the same universe
yeah yeah you could totally say that
yeah i will say though like i said
i mean trying to busan is kind of like a
hard act to follow i think what made
train to busan so good
was that it was very tightly focused
on like a core group of characters it
was took place in a relatively small
area over a small time period
and there was like a lot of you know
because there weren't that many
characters and they were all kind of
like in this confined space
um you had a lot more opportunity to get
like really emotionally invested in them
so like when somebody died in there
you're like oh [ __ ] no
like that guy i love that guy and stuff
like that i feel like this movie was
lacking a little bit of that
yeah i did like they introduced later
because you know at the beginning of the
movie
you're basically just getting this guy
who was i guess he was a marine right
and then it curry and marina yeah and
then like four years later and he's kind
of like down on his luck and he just you
know takes this
opportunity because he's been hanging
out with like a bunch of gangsters or
whatever he lost his family and
everything
yeah it was like well he i think he felt
responsible for getting his brother's
wife and child killed like on because
they were like trying to get the [ __ ]
off the peninsula and like there was an
outbreak on the boat or whatever that
was like at the beginning
so he kind of has all this guilt and he
can't really get past it
and so the the relationship between the
two of them is kind of
you know has a little bit of an
emotional core and then later on
when they're actually like they get
trapped on
you know where all the zombies and all
the bad guys are um
you know they meet this other family
that's like kind of in hiding and
they're just like kind of like hey why
don't you guys come with us so we can
leave or whatever
so they so they did like attempt to do
the same kind of thing
but i think that one thing that i think
that i didn't like about this movie is
too many bad guys
i think that there were too many um
villains and not enough
zombie action there was a lot of zombie
action i'm not saying that you could
really
see that they took inspiration from the
walking dead
yeah big time there was a lot of
inspiration but i didn't see i didn't
think that was bad it was just
it's different it's just different than
the first one this is it's a lot more
sprawling
my only gripe about the movie i like the
movie but my only gripe about it was
that there were two places
where koreans the koreans got a little
kimchi on me
[Laughter]
having lived in korea you kind of get
you kind of get it you kind of get
this you kind of see certain things that
koreans do one of one of the things that
koreans do sometimes is that they get
overly
melodramatic and during certain scenes
and they start playing
sad music and they start showing
everything in slow motion
and it kind of sucks the the wind out of
the damn movie
they're telling you how to feel about
the scene
yeah i don't want to be told how to feel
about the machine the scene you know
what i mean
it and what i'm talking about is
remember when his family got killed in
the uh when they were trying to escape
on the ship and they slowed everything
down and played the sad music
[Music]
it wasn't like that but you know what i
mean yeah it gets super super korean and
we would call that in the army you know
going
going real kimchi it's really really
it'd have been better if there was no
music at all
you know what i mean and maybe just like
heartbeats
oh yeah i like that idea with with with
like
no sound kind of like in uh saving
private ryan after a bomb hits that kind
of everything
everybody kind of zones out like you're
like your bell's wrong yeah
something like that i would have done
something like that
the melodramatic [ __ ] soft squishy
music
that's something koreans do in vancouver
that is something that i see because i
i remember seeing that like in the host
and stuff like that and i'm not [ __ ]
on it because that's just like how they
roll it's a cultural thing
and it's a cultural thing so it's like
i'm not really bothered and i love like
most korean horror movies i've seen have
been like really really
good it's a cultural thing they
shouldn't do it
that is those scenes would have been a
lot more
impactful had there been no no
music at all totally silent you're
watching those people
getting eaten up yeah you know what i
mean
kubrick doesn't do that he doesn't put
[ __ ] because in real life you don't
have like real life like
music spelling like oh no yeah
you don't have that yeah i try to make
it super emotional and that just takes
the emotional way
you should have an you should have a
natural reaction
to the carnage yeah i think i agree with
you on that
yeah and they shouldn't slow it down
they should let it happen in normal pace
yeah because and then you're like
stunned like wow that happened holy [ __ ]
yeah oh man or like that person died and
their death was
inconsequential well because that's kind
of like real life
yeah but that's the thing it's you could
argue that it's like well if you wanted
to see that you could just watch a
documentary
like where a bunch of inconsequential
[ __ ] like us like get killed or
something like that but
it's like when people watch movies maybe
they want like a little bit of a fantasy
aspect i don't know there's
there's good arguments on both sides
that's the way it really is though you
know there's your wife and child and
they're there one second and then boom
and then the zombies and it didn't make
any difference and the pace didn't even
slow down and you have to [ __ ]
survive
yeah there's no time to [ __ ] mope
about it
you're not even sure it actually
happened yeah i mean and then
it should hit you later yeah in the
movie you know
yeah that's that's how you really that's
how it was done in like real effective
war movies
saving private riot did that to the
whole thing yeah because you don't
really have the time to
reflect on it in the moment it's just
like later you feel bad
yeah right i will i will say that i mean
train to busan i think is one of the
very few horror movies where i actually
kind of cried at the end
because that [ __ ] was legit sad yeah
this one um
i kind of like the at the very very end
of it i'm not going to say what happened
at the end but i know some of you guys
have seen it but for those of you who
have not
i'm not going to say exactly what
happened but i did kind of be like
like that but i didn't like i wasn't
like full-on ballin or anything like
that
but i mean i think they did it took
until like
past the halfway point of the movie
because this movie's pretty long it was
almost like two hours which is pretty
long for
a zombie movie um but it took like until
past the halfway point when they
introduced
the other characters like the mom and
the two kids
um because prior to that most of the
characters were just
were just like dudes or like criminals
so it was kind of hard to
it was hard to relate to them or hard to
sympathize with them i guess
there was another dude on there that was
like he was a korean guy he was rock
army
and uh she stands for republic of korea
and he was probably about what maybe 10
15 years older than me
yeah something like that he was using a
lot of military jargon some of it was
english from
from the era that from the air in which
i served when i was in korea
just she's everybody's saying [ __ ] in
english like a strong soldier
and he's uh kind of lost his mind and
he's got his [ __ ] combo set up and
all this [ __ ] radios old
radios i think i think i saw singar's
radio and uh he's trying to
produce some power and he's trying to
talk to
the rock army combined [ __ ] forces
it's just funny you know he's
he's got an old k1 carbine and
just uh you know he's an old school
korean army guy probably was something
like it was he a colonel
oh i don't remember what did they call
him i think they said major but i could
i could be wrong
yeah i could be remembering iran yeah
but that was like the woman that was
there that was his daughter yeah
or was it just somebody he liked
somebody he adopted i thought it was his
daughter and his grandkids i thought
because they were calling him grandpa
were they okay the little girls all
right
he was trying to he was trying to rescue
the the girls in the he was trying to
get them out get him out of korea
and uh he's he's kind of crazy but as it
unfolds your eyes he's not as crazy as
you thought he was
but you know yeah which i don't want i
don't want to steal a thunder
yeah from that one um just to just know
that when you see that character
he's crazy but he's not that crazy yeah
he knows what's going
on well he's a good guy too and in a way
i kind of wish they had done a little
bit more with that character
yeah i wish he had been in it more
because i liked that character a lot
and he just seemed like he wasn't in it
that much well i think the idea was they
wanted you to blow him off because
because you just thought he thought it
was just crazy right that that was not
really the case because he's
going they're coming to get us something
yeah yeah people on the radio and he's
talking to the [ __ ] rock army
combined
forces and you know and all kinds of
[ __ ] and it doesn't happen you know but
eventually [ __ ] happens you'll see but
yeah so so like i said i'm not
because i have seen i feel like most of
the reviews that i saw of this or read
of this
were either meh or
i saw some reviews that they just hated
it they thought it was terrible oh it's
not terrible it's
i didn't think it was terrible at all
i'm just saying that it's a very
different movie than train to busan
um it's a totally different it's in the
same universe but it's not even the same
i mean it's much the scope of it is much
larger
there's like a lot more characters it's
a lot it's a lot less focused
yeah um and i feel like maybe it doesn't
have as strong an emotional core as
train to busan had because i think
that's what a lot of people liked about
that like liked the confined space they
liked
the the relatively small cast and uh
you know the way that you actually
really cared about the characters and
everyone's death was like you know had a
lot of impact
and i think this had a little bit less
of that
um just because so many of the
characters were criminals
um and also it was kind of like like
he's it kind of went in a direction
where
it was it's almost kind of going in the
direction of
like every other zombie movie which is
like a post-apocalyptic and like oh
we're all going to chain up zombies and
make people run away from them for
fun and [ __ ] you know you know what i
mean [ __ ] like that so i feel like
there's a lot of zombie movies that do
that
well there wasn't there wasn't much he
could do that's think about it that's
true
and you could not remake trying to busan
yeah and i'm actually i'm really glad
that he didn't try to
replicate it like oh well it's like
trained to busan but now it's on an
airplane you know what i mean or
something like that
that really would have been that's
that's what hollywood would have done
it's going to be like trying to boost on
but set them on trains on a plane
it's going to be or in a hot air balloon
yeah it's going to be yeah it's going to
be on a suburb or on the space shuttle
it's just going to be something stupid
and then they're going to retell
basically that same story with different
characters
this is totally different yeah it's
standalone i mean it's standalone
yeah essentially which um i can see why
people who like to train to busan might
have been disappointed but what was it
you thought
he was going to give you you thought he
was going to remake train to busan
that's not how yeah that's the kind of
thing that's and that's why i'm always
i'm always kind of like sequels are
always so difficult because you're kind
of damned if you do indeed
it's like people seem to want more of
the same but then if you give them more
of the same they give you well it's not
original but then if you
you did something completely different
then they would complain about that i'd
be like well it's nothing like the first
one
so i have to give him like props for
trying to do something like tell a
different story
in that universe with a few of the same
themes
and with the same you know zombies and
everything but
i just would have re-edited the score in
those two in those two scenes at the
very beginning and at the very end
where he started to go camp she looks on
me
[Laughter]
sad [ __ ] violin music and they're
slow now don't do that man
i can't remember i've trained a busan
had that dude no uh
it might have a little bit at the end
when the guy died he's
calling for his mom remember when the
when the villain guy died a little bit
but it wasn't it was pretty exaggerated
in those two scenes although i kind of
feel like maybe they just put that music
there at the end with that guy because
they wanted you to feel bad and i'm like
[ __ ] that guy
yeah that guy sucked
but uh don't try to make me feel bad
about him he was an [ __ ] i can see
why so
why some people didn't like it but you
know what [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them i liked it i like yeah i liked
it too i
didn't want it to sound like i didn't
like it but it's just like i i wasn't
actually sure what i was expecting i
wasn't really expecting anything a lot
of nighttime driving
action in zombieland and nighttime
car chases and a lot of car chases they
do a lot of stuff at night
um a lot of a lot of [ __ ] uh ar-15s a
lot of
korean k2 rifles military stuff that you
see on the credit card
a lot of gun battles a lot of guns uh
yeah they had uh
kind of like they they weren't
necessarily criminals i think they were
kind of like a mixture of like
rogue rogue soldiers yeah it was like
rogue military
military just people trying to like make
money and get by
and it looked like rogue military rogue
met ex-military guys and biker gangs and
stuff
that were had kind of grouped together
into a big survivalist gang
yeah and um they they kind of preyed on
the weak
too yeah it gave me and parts of it gave
me a little bit of an escape from new
york by yeah a little bit like
new york you know what i mean where it
was just kind of like this this huge
ruin of a place where people were just
trying to like eek out in existence
yeah so it had a lot of that as well and
like i said there was some
mad max kind of stuff and they evidently
were like scavenging for
johnny walker black they liked [ __ ]
good whiskey and stuff they were trying
to find the best of the stuff
that was around but there was still a
lot of stuff around yeah
cars and fuel and they had they had
everything guns and ammo
and uh they didn't really say much about
food they were eating a lot of ramen
yeah but it had only been four years so
stuff would still be around
yeah it's not like it had been like
[ __ ] yeah there weren't ever there
was still stuff that was like
and also you have to think too that
unlike in some other
you know much larger scope zombie movies
where it's just like a worldwide like
everyone's dead
this one seemed like the the zombies
have been mostly contained
right to this one small portion of the
world and like the the rest of the world
is kind of operating
more or less as normal yeah now the
korean population had declined so the
survivors were getting enough to eat
there was still countryside and stuff
yeah so and people were smuggling things
in and out
yeah of the korean peninsula and people
too
smuggling people out so you know it
wasn't
totally apocalyp apocalyptic yeah like i
said it wasn't it wasn't like a
situation like the road or something
like that where ever pretty much
everybody was dead and like nothing was
left around but yeah so
it's it's very weird to me that you
can't rent this maybe you can rent it
somewhere else but
it's weird because we were just because
i told him i was just like just pick a
new movie because we need to see a new
one
and he was like watching all the
trailers and he's like oh that looks
pretty good that looks pretty good
and then i wouldn't even have noticed it
if you hadn't just been like
systematically going down all the
and i was like holy [ __ ] like there
finally because we looked for it before
and i couldn't
we could you could buy it for cheaper
than you can rent a new hollywood movie
like
the mulan yeah yeah they want 20 bucks
for the rent
well when they come out new like they
always charge
20 bucks for like a few weeks and then
it drops down like
you know subsequently but there's yeah
there was a couple other ones on there
that were
i think had come down to maybe like four
bucks that you
might watch later um to review tomorrow
but i'm actually
kind of glad because we had been wanting
to see this for a really long time
so i'm glad we finally got around to
watching it like i said i didn't like it
as much as train to busan but
i don't like a lot of movies as much as
i like trying to be a song because that
was a [ __ ] awesome movie so you know
it's uh you know it's it's a different
thing it's a different zombie movie and
it was a lot of fun i liked a lot of the
car chases and
all the all the gags they kind of had
that little girl was kind of cute with
her little
remote control car and that little
teenage girl was kind of a badass so
that was like pretty cool
you know yeah um so anything else you
would like to add that's about it
all right so that'll do it for our
matinee today we'll be back again
tomorrow talking about another new movie
not sure which one yet we have a couple
in mind
so everybody thanks for stopping by have
a good rest of your day and we will see
you again tomorrow
bye